[Musique]
J'ai créé la Sea Shepherd
Conservation Society en 1977
en tant qu'organisation pour intervenir contre le
braconnage et les activités illégales en
haute mer. Nous sommes donc en réalité une
organisation anti-braconnage et nous
intervenons à l'échelle mondiale et nous le faisons avec ce que
j'appelle une non-agressivité.  -la violence, ce qui
est agressif, la non-violence, eh bien, nous sommes
agressifs, mais nous ne blessons jamais personne
et au cours de nos 40 années d'expérience,
nous n'avons jamais causé une seule blessure à qui que ce soit,
mais nous avons mis fin à
de nombreuses opérations de braconnage, vous
savez.  surpêche euh chasse à la baleine euh tuerie de requins tuerie de
tortues nous avons fermé ces
choses grâce à
une intervention agressive mais en même temps en faisant
très attention
à ne blesser personne,
comment imaginez-vous l'avenir de l'océan
de votre point de vue, sera-t-il
meilleur ou sur le  Au contraire, le pire, c'est que
l'avenir de l'océan est ce à quoi
nous assistons actuellement, c'est-à-dire
une diminution croissante de la
biodiversité. Nous avons perdu 90 pour cent
des poissons au cours des cent dernières années. Nous avons
eu une diminution de 40 pour cent de la
population de phytoplancton depuis.  1950, il y
a donc eu des situations très graves
qui se sont produites en termes de
diminution de la biodiversité. Le problème
est que la plupart des gens n'en sont pas conscients d'ici
2048, selon le Dr Boris Worm de l'
Université de Dalhousie et le Dr Daniel
Pauley de l'Université de la
Colombie-Britannique qui sont les  deux éminents
scientifiques océanographiques de la pêche, euh, il
n'y aura pas d'industrie de la pêche en
19 en 2048 parce qu'il n'y aura pas de
poisson, il
n'y aura pas de récifs coralliens,
donc ce que nous regardons est un
désastre écologique dans nos océans
et cela n'augure rien de bon pour l'
avenir de l'humanité car comme je le
dis toujours, si l'océan meurt, nous mourrons, nous ne
vivons pas sur cette planète avec un océan mort
et à mesure que l'océan diminue, notre
capacité à survivre est diminuée,
mais au final  à la même époque aujourd'hui, il semble que
malgré votre combat, l'humanité ne
mesure pas si concrètement l'impact de la perte des
notions de biodiversité, quand les
choses vont-elles changer et comment
cela pourrait-il changer
pendant des centaines et des années maintenant, euh,
depuis des millions d'années, euh, l'océan
a  été le système de survie de l'
autre planète si vous regardez la Terre
comme un vaisseau spatial qui voyage
à travers l'espace, c'est ce que c'est. Chaque
vaisseau spatial a un système de survie et
il fournit la nourriture que nous mangeons, il régule
la température, contrôle la  le climat et
il fournit l'air que nous respirons et
ce système de survie se trouve
dans l'océan et ce
système de survie est géré par un équipage, un équipage de euh sur
cette planète, qui
sont toutes ces différentes espèces qui
le font fonctionner, nous  nous ne sommes pas un équipage, nous sommes des passagers,
nous passons un bon moment à
nous divertir, mais ce que nous faisons, c'est
tuer l'équipage, le phytoplancton
qui produit l'oxygène, les baleines qui
fournissent les nutriments au
phytoplancton, euh, l'
interrelation avec tout  l'espèce
qui fait tout fonctionner et qui a
tout fait fonctionner pendant des millions d'
années, nous compromettons sérieusement l'
efficacité de cela, que se passe-t-il si vous le regardez
en termes de machines qui
maintiennent la vie et c'est une situation très grave, euh,
diminution de quarante pour cent
du phytoplancton  La population depuis 1950
est une situation grave dont personne n'est vraiment
conscient. Le phytoplancton
fournit entre 50 et 70, voire
peut-être même 80 pour cent de tout l'
oxygène que nous respirons, le reste provenant des
arbres et des plantes et si vous supprimez le
phytoplancton qui est maintenant sérieusement menacé.
épuisés, nous n'aurons tout simplement plus d'
oxygène pour respirer et la
relation entre le phytoplancton et les
baleines est que les baleines fournissent les
nutriments pour le phytoplancton, le fer et
l'azote, principalement à travers les excréments
semblables au fumier de cheval pour
fournir de l'engrais dans une ferme, donc les
baleiniers, les baleines sont  en fait,
les agriculteurs de l'océan, mais nous ne
savons pas que nous ne sommes pas
assez intelligents pour vraiment comprendre toutes ces
interrelations et l'
interdépendance de toutes ces espèces
et euh, en tant que tels, nous épuisons cette
capacité de l'océan.  les écosystèmes pour
soutenir la vie sur cette planète
je suis sûr que vous avez entendu parler de la coupe 21 la
conférence des partis à paris
à la fin de l'événement médiatique l'ancienne
présidente de la coupe lauren fabius
a parlé d'un accord historique
maintenant nous sommes six mois plus tard  quel est votre
sentiment sur ces accords et
pensez-vous que la conférence a poussé les gens
et les entreprises à prendre conscience de l'urgence
de la situation, et bien le flic 21 n'a été qu'un
événement nul,
rien n'en est sorti, c'était une excellente
occasion pour tous les dirigeants du monde de se
féliciter  ils ont fait des
séances de photos sur la manière dont ils vont
sauver la planète, mais ils n'ont discuté de
rien de pertinent.
J'ai présenté un livret sur les solutions au
changement climatique que personne ne veut entendre
et ils ne voulaient certainement pas entendre
et ils n'en ont certainement pas discuté
et le fait est que si nous voulons
protéger cette planète des
conséquences du changement climatique et que
nous devons permettre à l'océan de se réparer,
cela signifie que nous devons arrêter toutes les
opérations de pêche industrialisées, nous
devons arrêter les subventions aux
opérations de pêche industrialisées, vous savez que cela prend
du temps et si nous n'y sommes pas disposés,
les océans vont mourir. Une
autre solution à cela est que nous
devons passer à des régimes alimentaires à base de plantes, car
nous tuons 65 milliards de personnes.  animaux chaque
année et cela sans compter ceux
que nous retirons de l'océan et l'
industrie de l'élevage
contribue plus de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère que l'ensemble de l'
industrie des transports et
consomme également plus d'eau crée des zones mortes
et est l'
une des causes les plus graves de
la pollution à la fois dans les eaux souterraines et dans l'
océan et euh mais personne ne veut vraiment
aborder ces solutions, ils veulent
trouver des
réponses qui sont d'abord, vous savez, qui
sont acceptables et qui n'affectent pas notre
style de vie et en même temps
les gouvernements veulent trouver des solutions
à travers la fiscalité, ils pensent que c'est
une bonne occasion de taxer tout le monde
afin d'obtenir cet argent, mais comme je l'ai
constaté avec les taxes environnementales à travers
le monde, lorsqu'elles sont collectées,
elles ne servent pas à résoudre le
problème, elles vont essentiellement à ce qui
Les gouvernements dépensent généralement leur argent et le
gaspillent dans des choses ridicules
comme la défense, les
subventions ou
leur propre masse salariale.
D'un point de vue, la France est-elle impliquée
dans les questions céréalières ou est-elle complètement aveugle? La
France n'est pas différente de tout
autre pays, ce qui signifie que la France,
comme  tous ces autres pays ne font
rien pour résoudre les vrais problèmes,
vous savez, on prétend qu'il y a
des choses qui se font, mais juste sur les océans,
par exemple, la France contrôle euh le
deuxième plus grand territoire maritime de la
planète, euh, la marine française a une
merveilleuse opportunité  pour
faire respecter les opérations illégales euh contre les
opérations de pêche illégales mais ils ne font pas
grand chose et j'en ai parlé à
l'amiral de la marine française et
il est d'accord euh mais il a dit
que leurs mains sont liées politiquement,
quel est votre sentiment  à propos de Nikolai Hulu,
je pense que Nikolai bonjour, c'est certainement que vous le
savez, quand il préparait le
flic 21,
je pense qu'il s'est rendu compte que ça
n'allait pas, euh, ça n'allait pas
réaliser ce qu'il espérait
et je pense  il a été assez déçu
à ce sujet, je pense qu'il est probablement le euh
le seul à occuper une sorte de
position politique en France à qui
veut sincèrement trouver une réponse.
Votre organisation C Shepherd a subi
quelques critiques, par exemple certaines personnes ont
souligné votre manque de tolérance.
envers les activités des populations pauvres par
exemple vous avez fait une campagne dans l'union
pour protéger les requins et en fait la
population locale était perplexe car il
s'agissait de dizaines de requins alors que les
navires français pêchent des milliers de tonnes de requins
chaque année et il n'y a pas de campagne
là-bas  alors acceptez-vous et comprenez-vous
ces critiques
d'abord sur la première question, nous ne
ciblons
personne
qui n'agit pas illégalement,
donc je m'en fiche de savoir si les gens sont
riches ou pauvres s'ils enfreignent la loi,
nous allons le faire  opposons-nous à eux, mais là où ce que
nous faisons principalement, c'est d'aller à l'
encontre des grandes entreprises de pêche,
je veux dire, nous parlons d'
entreprises de plusieurs millions de dollars qui
pillent littéralement les océans en ce
moment. Nous avons un de nos navires qui travaille
en partenariat avec le  le gouvernement du
Gabon a mis fin à la
pêche illégale dans les eaux gabonaises la
semaine dernière, nous avons arrêté trois navires chinois
qui exploitaient illégalement ces eaux le
mois dernier, nous avons pourchassé
six
filets dérivants chinois japonais illégaux
depuis l'océan
vers la Chine et les avons remis à  le
gouvernement chinois avec les preuves d'
activités illégales euh nous travaillons en
partenariat avec la marine mexicaine pour
sauver le vaquita en voie de disparition et euh oui ce
sont de pauvres pêcheurs qui s'en
prennent à ce vaquita mais ils le font
illégalement donc nous en avons saisi 20
euh  25 longues files d'attente et environ 42
filets maillants installés illégalement et nous avons confisqué ceux dont
vous savez que vous ne pouvez pas utiliser
la pauvreté comme excuse pour ce genre d'
infraction à la loi, sinon ce serait
certainement tout à fait acceptable que les gens
vendent de la cocaïne parce qu'ils sont pauvres
c'est certainement bien de braquer les banques
parce qu'elles sont pauvres, donc si vous regardez
l'océan comme une banque qui contient
les économies ou les investissements pour l'
avenir de toute l'humanité, alors les braconniers
ne sont pas différents des braqueurs de banque,
oh et ainsi de suite.  la question permet
les retrouvailles
il y en a tu sais
chaque année euh le nombre moyen de
personnes tuées par les requins est de sept
ce qui est étonnant quand on considère que
chaque jour environ 300 millions de personnes vont
dans l'océan donc tu sais que tes chances
d'être tué par un requin sont  assez
petit en fait, il est plus dangereux
de jouer au golf si vous jouez au golf, vos
chances d'être frappé par la foudre ou
d'être piqué par une abeille et de mourir sont
plus grandes et plus de personnes meurent sur les
terrains de golf chaque année que ne sont attaquées par
les requins dont nous avons besoin  les requins, ils ont façonné
l'évolution de notre océan pendant 450 millions
d'années, ils sont un prédateur suprême et
ils sont essentiels à l'
intégrité écologique de l'océan, il
n'y a donc aucune excuse pour les tuer, le
problème est que ce sont les trois endroits dans le
monde où les attaques de requins
sont plus répandus sont le Queensland, l'
Australie occidentale et l'île de la Réunion
et qu'est-ce que ces trois endroits ont en
commun, ils ont des programmes de destruction des requins, c'est-à-dire qu'ils éliminent les requins
et sont
financés par le gouvernement pour le faire maintenant,
qu'est-ce que cela fait, les requins sont des
créatures territoriales, par conséquent  lorsque vous entrez et que
vous tuez des requins dans une zone, vous créez un
vide qui attire davantage de requins dans cette
zone et ces requins sont par nature
territoriaux et deviennent très agressifs
en tant que jockey pour se positionner sur ce
territoire, d'où ces programmes à la
Réunion, dans le Queensland et dans l'ouest.  L'Australie
crée des requins agressifs et
donc la responsabilité des
attaques de requins incombe désormais aux personnes qui
tuent les requins. Le gouvernement
français contribue en fait à ces
attaques de requins et quant aux surfeurs qui
s'en plaignent au sein de notre
conseil consultatif, nous avons de la chance.  avoir Kelly
Slater qui est probablement le meilleur
surfeur du monde et je pense que le conseil de Kelly
aux surfeurs lors de nombreuses réunions était
tout à fait approprié, il a dit euh si vous avez
peur des requins, restez en dehors de l'
océan, vous n'y êtes pas à votre place, n'est-ce pas  Je
pense que Greenpeace a suffisamment de pouvoir pour
influencer les décisions politiques en
Australie. Greenpeace est une entreprise tout
comme le Fonds mondial pour la nature.
Ils sont là pour vendre des
sentiments de bien-être.
Rejoignez Greenpeace, vous faites partie de la
solution, vous ne faites pas partie du problème l'
année dernière.  Greenpeace a apporté 375
millions d'euros, ils ont dépensé 170 millions d'
euros pour obtenir cet argent, c'est un
investissement pour un retour,
vous savez, ils avaient trois navires qui font
très peu l'
année dernière, Sea Shepherd a apporté 12
millions d'euros, nous avons neuf navires
là-bas tout le temps et  donc nous faisons
plus avec moins parce que nous avons réalisé il y a
longtemps que l'argent n'est pas la solution,
c'est la passion, l'imagination et le
courage des bénévoles
impliqués, donc nous ne dépensons rien pour collecter de l'
argent et l'argent que nous rapportons.
nous dépensons pour des programmes et nous accomplissons
davantage,
on sait que vous n'êtes pas sur la même
longueur d'onde avec Greenpeace, mais certains de vos
partisans suivent Greenpeace
et vous
pensez peut-être que vous êtes complémentaire,
alors pourriez-vous imaginer un partenariat ou le
ferez-vous toujours  combattez-vous bien les uns les autres, tout d'abord,
nous ne combattons pas Greenpeace,
mais nous combattons les attitudes lorsque
Greenpeace soutient la chasse au phoque, nous nous y
opposons lorsque Greenpeace soutient la chasse à la baleine, nous nous opposons à eux
lorsque Greenpeace
soutient la chasse aux ours polaires, nous nous y
opposons, ils ne sont pas là.  du même côté,
si vous soutenez l'abattage commercial des
phoques, vous n'êtes pas de notre côté et
nous allons donc contester cela,
donc je ne défie pas Greenpeace sur la
base du fait qu'il est Greenpeace, je
les défie sur les positions qui
ce qu'ils soutiennent, ce à quoi nous sommes opposés,
cela vaut également pour le
Fonds mondial pour la nature. Nous travaillons principalement avec
des organisations de base à travers le
monde. C'est là que réside la force du
mouvement de conservation de l'environnement
et ce genre de diversité, vous savez, il y en
a environ trois millions.  des
organisations environnementales non gouvernementales
enregistrées dans le monde entier et c'est
la force de tout le mouvement,
pas les grandes organisations mais toutes
ces petites organisations, ce sont
elles qui font la différence, ce
ne sont pas elles qui ont l'argent qu'elles ont
ceux qui ont la passion et ce sont
ceux avec qui nous travaillons en alliance
quel est votre sentiment sur la jeune
génération pensez-vous qu'ils se soucient de
la situation qu'ils comprennent ou
du pays qu'ils ont
bien abandonné il y a beaucoup de tout  de cela, les
jeunes sont certainement beaucoup plus
conscients
aujourd'hui qu'il y a
20, 30 ou 40 ans, je veux dire en
1972, personne ne savait même ce que le mot
écologie signifiait, et les gens
étaient certainement aveugles aux vrais problèmes, donc je
pense que les jeunes sont beaucoup plus conscients
maintenant.
sont-ils impliqués oui, les gens sont
distraits par tout, des
jeux vidéo au divertissement ou autre, mais je
vois un niveau d'implication probablement
plus grand que jamais dans l'histoire précédente
et les jeunes sont en fait confrontés à un
défi très intimidant que les autres
générations avant eux  Je n'ai pas eu à y faire
face et ce défi est le fait
que cette planète ne sera peut-être pas vivable
à la fin de ce siècle et cela
va gravement affecter, vous savez, leur
vie,
donc euh, les obstacles sont très réels
et parfois ils sont  assez écrasant,
je crois que lorsque vous êtes
confronté à une situation impossible et à des
probabilités écrasantes, vous devez trouver
des solutions impossibles et je crois que ces
solutions peuvent être trouvées à nouveau grâce à
l'imagination, à la passion et au courage et je
vois de plus en plus cela chez les jeunes.
les gens,
nous avons neuf navires sur ces navires en ce
moment, nous avons environ 125 volontaires de 20
ou 25 pays différents, tout dépend
et
nous avons donc des milliers de personnes qui veulent
participer, donc je
vois certainement la passion des gens qui veulent
qui  veulent s'impliquer et ils
veulent s'impliquer parce que lorsqu'ils
rejoignent nos navires, ils peuvent réellement avoir
la satisfaction de voir les résultats de
leurs efforts. Ils coulent, ils
arrêtent une opération de pêche illégale ou
ils sauvent x nombre de baleines ou ils en
sauvent x nombre.  des tortues sur les plages du
Costa Rica, par exemple,
ce sont des résultats réels et cela
donne donc aux gens non seulement la satisfaction
de le faire, mais aussi l'encouragement
qu'ils peuvent faire plus parce que je crois
que tout le monde a la
capacité de changer les choses pour changer
le monde  et que nous encourageons cette
initiative individuelle, cet individu euh
une imagination individuelle pour trouver ces
solutions, est-ce que les gens à bord paient pour cela non non
non ils montent à bord, ils sont
logés et nourris
et euh, ils n'ont pas à payer  pour
rejoindre maintenant, le seul paiement, je suppose, est
quel que soit leur billet d'avion pour rejoindre
le navire où qu'il soit dans le monde si
c'est en Australie vol en Australie si
c'est en Afrique, ils doivent voler vers l'
Afrique mais il n'y a en fait aucun coût
impliqué en fait  nous n'avons même pas d'
adhésion au sein de
Sea Shepherd, nous avons des supporters
mais nous n'avons pas d'adhésion fixe, ce qui
pourrait être votre conseil pour la jeune
génération.
Mon conseil
est vraiment que les gens suivent leurs
passions et vous savez si  ils sont
intéressés par quelque chose pour le poursuivre
euh tu sais je trouve qu'une personne
qui défend une cause fait la différence
euh à cause d'une montagne de Diane Pitey qui a
survécu au Rwanda euh le travail de
Jane Goodall Breutigeltikos quand elle
protège les orangs-outans en Indonésie ce
sont  exemples d'individus qui font la
différence en raison de leur passion
un homme aux
Bermudes David Wingate à cause
de lui la tempête des Bermudes l'essence n'a pas
disparu je veux dire je ne peux penser à
rien de plus euh vous savez un plus grand
héritage à laisser que le fait  que vous
viviez dans une espèce entière, on a euh
empêché de disparaître et donc
j'encourage les gens du monde entier quand
ils viennent me voir et ils me disent eh bien, je suis
vraiment préoccupé par vous savez, dites de
protéger les jaguars au euh au Belize, j'ai
dit bien alors  alors faites cela, vous savez,
faites tout ce que vous pouvez en utilisant votre imagination
et trouvez des moyens de vous impliquer
et de faire des choses comme ça, donc c'est ce que
nous essayons de faire, c'est d'encourager les gens à
suivre leurs propres passions,
bientôt il y aura une
élection présidentielle à  les États-Unis
pour vous qui pourraient être le candidat de base
pour défendre les questions vertes, il n'y en a pas, il
n'y en a pas un qui soit comme essayer de
choisir entre vous savez, euh, la couleur et
la variole, vraiment,
il n'y a pas de meilleur type de candidat qui
pourrait être le pire des  Le pire,
eh bien, tu as le choix entre un
idiot de Donald Trump ou un psychopathe comme
Hillary Clinton, je veux dire, c'est fondamentalement
ton choix, euh le problème c'est que les
États-Unis ne sont pas une démocratie, c'est un
aliarki et ils choisissent déjà le
président avant que quiconque n'y arrive.
votez, personnellement, je soutenais Bernie
Sanders et je crois qu'il aurait
gagné s'ils n'avaient pas truqué les élections
contre lui
et que les médias ont refusé de les couvrir
parce que les médias sont contrôlés par les
mêmes personnes qui contrôlent les entreprises
qui décident qui est  tu vas être président
et donc tu n'auras pas vraiment de
représentation démocratique dans un
pays où les entreprises ont le
dernier mot
et c'est à peu près vrai pour
tout, par exemple
Justin Trudeau est venu à
Paris un mois après avoir été élu
Premier ministre  Justin Trudeau du
Canada ouais, un mois après avoir été
élu premier ministre du Canada, il est venu
à Paris
et il était tout excité, il va
vraiment faire quelque chose contre le changement climatique, je
veux dire, il est très idéaliste et il a
amené environ 150 personnes avec eux
et ils  tous se sont assis et ils étaient très
très sérieux, puis il est rentré chez lui mais
il n'était Premier ministre que depuis un
mois, donc quand il est rentré chez lui,
les gens qui contrôlent vraiment les choses
ont dû l'asseoir et lui parler
parce que maintenant il soutient le
pipeline, il soutient le projet des sables bitumineux,
il dit que les incendies
qu'ils ont eu en Alberta ne sont pas
liés au changement climatique, donc il
devient comme tout le monde, c'est
essentiellement parce que ce ne sont que des marionnettes à qui on dit
quoi faire, ce n'est pas nous.
il n'y a pas de dirigeants mondiaux, nous
avons essentiellement des marionnettes contrôlées par les
sociétés qui contrôlent
tout, les sociétés mineures, les sociétés
forestières, les grandes
sociétés de pêche, les pays dotés d'énergie nucléaire, ce
sont eux qui contrôlent tout
et ce soi-disant vote n'est qu'un simple vote.
c'est juste une mascarade,
tu ne vas pas, c'est pourquoi nous n'avons jamais
quelqu'un qui fait quoi que ce soit,
il y a un rapport, une pétition sur
Internet contre toi parce que tu as
Brigitte Bardo comme amie sur Facebook, que
leur réponds-tu, je ne sais pas  je
n'ai aucune politique ni à droite ni
à gauche, je trouve en fait assez drôle
que même si la droite m'accuse d'
être de gauche, la gauche
m'accuse d'être de droite,
je n'ai pas de politique, je crois que la
protection de  notre océan
est ce que tout le monde a en commun,
quelle que soit votre religion, quelle que soit
votre politique, peu importe qui ou
où vous êtes,
nous avons tous cet intérêt commun
de protéger notre océan, donc je ne suis pas
vraiment préoccupé par ces
concepts anthropocentriques que vous connaissez.
c'est à cela que servent la politique et la religion, ce sont des
concepts anthropocentriques, ce que nous avons fait au cours des derniers
milliers d'années, c'est mettre en place ce
système dans lequel nous nous sommes déclarés
êtres les êtres suprêmes presque comme
des dieux dans notre propre esprit et cela  rien
d'autre n'a d'importance nous sommes responsables de
tout nous sommes plus importants que
tout je ne crois pas que nous
ne soyons pas plus importants que quoi que ce soit en fait les
vers, les arbres et les abeilles sont plus
importants que nous parce
qu'ils peuvent vivre sans nous  nous ne pouvons pas vivre
sans eux, cela les rend plus
importants que nous, donc je ne me
mêle pas de politique. Tout ce que je sais si
avec Brigitte Bardot, c'est que pendant trois
ans, nous avons essayé d'
attirer l'attention du monde sur le massacre de  les phoques
dans l'est du Canada, personne n'y a prêté attention,
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai appris une leçon si vous
voulez attirer l'attention des gens, vous devez
respecter les règles
établies par les médias
et les médias ne comprennent que quatre
choses, le scandale sexuel, la violence et
la célébrité, donc si vous voulez un  histoire, vous
devez incorporer ces éléments dans
l'histoire, c'est pourquoi certaines personnes disent que
vous êtes sexiste,
et bien personnellement, je m'en fiche de ce qu'ils
pensent,
je ne suis pas là pour les satisfaire, mes clients
sont des baleines, des tortues, des phoques et
des requins et  les oiseaux et
je m'en fous de ce que les gens
pensent de moi je ne suis pas là pour les représenter est-ce que
tu fais confiance aux gens non je m'en fiche
du tout euh mais le problème c'est que dis moi
pourquoi et bien laisse-moi d'abord  je viens de
terminer ce que je disais, désolé pour
ça, en l'amenant sur la
glace, nous avons garanti une couverture
mondiale, sa photo est apparue dans tous
les magazines et nous avons accompli plus avec
sa seule visite sur la glace que nous n'en avions
accompli en trois ans de travail.
l'activisme donc c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai réalisé que
nous devions incorporer des célébrités
parce qu'elles sont des médias
euh c'est une sorte de hacking c'est une sorte de
hack
tu sais c'est quoi un hacker un hacker ouais je
suppose qu'on pourrait le dire c'est
une sorte de high majeur  un peu comme le
piratage des médias, je suppose que vous savez, il y a six mois,
j'ai écrit un discours à prononcer
au gouvernement russe, ils ne vont pas
m'écouter, mais ce que je voulais faire,
c'était les amener à arrêter les
transports de baleines à travers le  l'Arctique
à travers leurs eaux,
alors j'ai écrit le discours. J'ai demandé à Pamela
Anderson d'aller en
Russie et de prononcer le discours. Ils ne se sont pas contentés de
l'écouter, ils lui ont fait une
standing ovation et ils ont agi conformément à ce que
nous leur avons demandé de faire.
Pourquoi parce que Pamela Anderson est une forme de
médias
et donc nous utilisons des célébrités et elles
se permettent d'être utilisées comme une forme de média, c'est
pourquoi nous traitons avec elles et
je ne suis vraiment pas intéressé par la
politique de ces célébrités, je
m'intéresse au fait qu'elles  sont
comme une chaîne de télévision ou un
journal, un moyen de transmettre un
message,
quelle est votre opinion sur Poutine,
il est comme un autre leader mondial, je
n'en ai pas, est-il une marionnette là-bas, eh bien, ce
sont tous les marionnettes des autres, vous savez,
euh, ceux de Poutine  probablement moins une marionnette
basée sur le fait qu'il est un
dictateur en soi, mais qui sait
qui tire les ficelles là-bas, je ne
sais pas, je sais qu'aucun
changement réel ne vient de
la politique, quel que soit ce système de
gouvernement.  c'est qu'ils
sont tous redevables
du statu quo économique,
ils investissent tous à court terme
pour des gains à court terme
sans ver, je ne peux pas penser à un
seul dirigeant politique dans le monde qui
regarde vers l'avenir dans 100 ans  et
dit à quoi ressemblera ce monde
à cause de ce que nous faisons en ce moment, je
ne connais pas un seul d'entre eux qui
fait cela,
quelle est votre opinion sur l'
interdiction de chanter, vous savez qu'aucune espèce n'a
jamais survécu sur cette planète  en dehors
des trois lois fondamentales de l'écologie, la
première est la loi de la diversité, la
force d'un écosystème réside dans la
diversité en son sein, la seconde est la
loi de l'interdépendance, de sorte que les espèces
au sein de cet écosystème dépendent les
unes des autres et la troisième est la loi de l'écologie.
ressources limitées il y a une limite à la
croissance une limite à une capacité de charge
ce que nous, les humains, faisons en ce moment, c'est
voler la capacité de charge d'autres
espèces, ils doivent disparaître pour faire de la
place à un plus grand nombre d'entre nous, mais
cela diminue l'interdépendance
et la diversité  ce qui peut
conduire à un effondrement de l'ensemble du système
même si cela se produit si nous voulons
sortir d'un effondrement
que se passe-t-il ce qui est réel s'est-il passé
ce qui se passera dans un effondrement la
civilisation cessera d'exister nous pourrions
disparaître
c'est euh assez simple  euh parce que nous
ne pouvons pas survivre sans oxygène, nous ne pouvons pas
survivre sans nourriture et nous ne pouvons pas
survivre sans emballement, c'était un
changement climatique incontrôlable, donc nous ne survivons pas, c'est
vraiment ce que
sont les conséquences finales, la seule façon pour nous
de survivre est d'apprendre à  vivre en
harmonie avec toutes les autres
espèces citoyennes de cette planète, nous devons
apprécier et comprendre le rôle
qu'elles jouent, le rôle que les baleines jouent, le rôle que les
poissons jouent le rôle que jouent les oiseaux,
ils contribuent tous à ce
système de survie que
nous pouvons'  Je ne continue pas à agir comme si nous étions la
seule espèce qui compte, que pourriez-vous
nous dire sur l'équipe Kuster,
commençons par le capitaine et qu'en est-il de
la plus jeune équipe que
j'ai connue, Jack Cousteau, je l'ai rencontré à plusieurs
reprises et euh
je pense qu'il  était un homme en avance sur son
temps, il a certainement euh beaucoup contribué
à l'éducation mondiale sur euh sur les
écosystèmes marins euh donc en tant qu'éducateur
il était plutôt euh
il a vraiment beaucoup contribué
et la plus jeune équipe et bien je ne m'entends pas
avec  jean-michel
cousteau mais euh avec euh avec les
enfants euh tu connais les petits-enfants et
tout ce avec quoi je m'entends plutôt bien euh
et j'ai travaillé avec eux et j'ai
parlé avec eux je pense que tu sais
ça
c'est une famille qui est symbolique
de
conscience océanique et je suis vraiment heureux
de voir qu'ils sont impliqués, vous savez,
toute la famille est impliquée d'une manière
ou d'une autre et ils apportent une
contribution je les aime bien, avez-vous vu
ce qu'on appelle le septième continent ou le
grand Pacifique  Garbett Patch, je sais de quoi vous
parlez, nous menons une
campagne sur le plastique depuis des années, cela
s'appelle le projet Vortex
et ce que nous faisons, c'est nettoyer les plages
partout dans le monde. Nous collectons des tonnes et des
tonnes de plastique du monde entier
et  envoyez-le pour le recyclage, nous
l'expédions à un endroit central pour être recyclé
euh l'année dernière, nous avons ramené 72 kilomètres
70 tonnes de filet maillant de l'
océan austral et nous l'avons transformé en chaussures,
donc nous cherchons aussi  pour
les alternatives au plastique,
nous avons actuellement un projet pour trouver
des alternatives aux pailles en plastique
et nous travaillons également avec une
entreprise à San Malo qui
fabrique du plastique à partir d'algues, donc il est
en fait biodégradable,
donc c'est une combinaison de nettoyage du
plastique, euh  décourager l'utilisation du
plastique et trouver des alternatives au
plastique c'est un grand projet pour Sea
Shepherd quel est votre sentiment à propos de
Fukushima et bien Fukushima est quelque chose
dont les gens ne veulent pas vraiment parler
parce que je veux parler ouais
je sais mais en général  en général, ils
ne veulent pas en parler parce qu'il
n'y a pas de solutions euh les
japonais essaient de dissimuler les
dégâts mais les dégâts sont extrêmes et
ils continueront à l'être. De
l'eau radioactive s'infiltre dans les
eaux souterraines de
Tokyo.  En le jetant dans l'océan,
nous en voyons les effets sur les poissons
au large des côtes de la Californie et
certainement en Alaska, c'est une
tragédie majeure, euh, qui a été minimisée par les
médias mondiaux
et euh, mais le problème est
que
comment faire  vous vous en occupez, vous ne pouvez pas, vous
ne pouvez pas vraiment le nettoyer, mais ce que cela
annonce, c'est que la situation similaire
se produit
dans d'autres endroits dans le monde la
semaine dernière, la centrale nucléaire de Diablo
a été fermée en Californie et nous
J'essaie de le faire fermer depuis
des années parce qu'il chevauche en fait deux
lignes de faille, mais ils ont construit un
réacteur nucléaire sur une ligne de faille sismique majeure,
deux lignes de faille sismiques majeures, alors ils
l'ont fermé, comment ils vont le
démanteler, je ne le fais pas.  Je ne sais pas, mais on se rend
compte que
ces centrales nucléaires peuvent avoir des
conséquences très très graves
à chaque fois qu'il y a
un accident comme Tchernobyl ou Fukushima
et
qu'en seulement une génération, nous avons vraiment
eu
deux,
presque trois
accidents nucléaires majeurs et  cela n'augure rien de
bon pour l'avenir de l'
énergie nucléaire dans le monde,
que pensez-vous de la politique nucléaire française? Je
suis certainement opposé aux
centrales nucléaires.
vous avez, vous
avez 7,5 milliards de personnes,
comment fournissez-vous de l'énergie à cela euh il y a le
nucléaire il y a le feu de charbon il y a le pétrole il y a il y a des
moulins à vent
et tout mais le problème est que
toute notre population
mondiale dépend des combustibles fossiles
vous savez, les gens pensent que l'énergie nucléaire
est propre  ce n'est pas le cas, il s'agit en fait d'une
utilisation très intensive de combustibles fossiles, car pour
fabriquer une once
d'uranium, vous avez besoin de mille tonnes de
mélange de brai, ce qui signifie que vous
devez l'extraire, vous devez le broyer, vous
devez le fabriquer, vous avez  pour le
transporter, la quantité de combustibles fossiles
utilisée dans l'industrie nucléaire à elle seule
dépasse presque celle-ci et est utilisée dans
les centrales électriques au pétrole et au charbon, donc ce n'est pas une
énergie propre, c'est un fantasme, c'est une énergie
propre,
mais
le problème est en réalité une trop grande
consommation d'énergie par un trop grand nombre  les gens
produisent trop de produits qui
ne servent à rien du tout
nous devons vraiment réduire les
produits inutiles nous devons trouver des moyens d'
arrêter la croissance de la population humaine de
manière responsable c'est une sorte de
théorie de la maltraitance
oui mais quelle est votre opinion  à propos de ça, c'est ce que
je veux dire, mais la population
ne dépassera pas 12 millions, 12
milliards, c'est la limite
parce qu'elle s'effondrera avant, ce
n'est tout simplement pas la planète qui ne peut tout simplement pas
soutenir 12 milliards de personnes, cela
n'arrivera pas et cela va
avant la fin de ce siècle,
il va s'effondrer
et j'en
suis absolument convaincu. Maintenant,
la solution
est compliquée, mais vous savez, ce que je
trouve vraiment frustrant, c'est quand les gens
disent que vous savez, les gens intelligents disent que
je ne vais pas le faire.  J'ai des enfants
parce que tu sais que je ne vais pas
contribuer à ce problème
mais ils représentent moins de trois pour
cent de la population totale, les
gens qui sont suffisamment conscients pour
dire cela
et euh je dis toujours que ce sont des gens qui auraient
probablement dû avoir  les enfants parce que
vous savez, sinon nous élevons simplement
des générations et des générations de personnes
qui n'ont absolument aucune usure ni
conscience du tout. En fait, je pense qu'ils ont
fait un super film à ce sujet appelé
idiocratie où, dans 500 ans, nous
vivrons dans un monde de gens stupides.  mais
le problème c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
solutions faciles mais des solutions
doivent être trouvées et je pense que nous
devons aussi vraiment nous concentrer sur la
réduction de nos niveaux de consommation de
matériaux et
au lieu que les nations du tiers monde essaient de
devenir les premières nations du monde.
les nations du monde devraient envisager de
nous abaisser à un niveau de
consommation inférieur, comment êtes-vous au courant
de la soi-disant théorie,
son nom est picoille,
vous savez, choisir de l'huile, choisir de l'huile ouais, quelle est
votre opinion à ce sujet, c'est une terreur, c'est
quoi, ils  Si ce sont des
ressources limitées, elles vont s'effondrer et en ce
moment nous assistons déjà à l'utilisation
de la fracturation hydraulique et d'autres technologies pour
extraire de moins en moins de ce qui est
disponible
et
donc le problème avec le pétrole est que c'est une drogue
toute notre civilisation
en dépend.  cette drogue, nous sommes des drogués, nous sommes
des drogués du pétrole et comme les drogués, nous ferons
tout pour l'obtenir et cela signifie
détruire la planète sur laquelle nous vivons pour l'obtenir,
nous allons le faire et si cela
signifie tuer des gens dans les pays du tiers monde
si  cela signifie détruire notre océan,
nous allons le faire parce que nous sommes
dépendants de cette drogue, je veux dire, regardez
les guerres que nous menons actuellement à ce sujet,
d'ici 2030, nous serons probablement dans une
guerre majeure sur le continent antarctique
parce que c'est la dernière réserve inexploitée
non seulement de pétrole mais aussi de cobalt et d'
autres charbons, par exemple des
veines de charbon de 200 mètres traversant les
montagnes transantarctiques, elles sont intactes
pour le moment, mais ils y vont et quand
ils le feront, vous y allez  voir des
aventures militaires majeures en Antarctique, donc les guerres
du 20e et
du 21e siècle seront des guerres pour les
ressources
et pas seulement pour le pétrole,
mais aussi pour l'eau, nous allons
avoir des conflits très sérieux
sur la disponibilité de l'eau,
donc d'une certaine manière, à l'échelle
mondiale  le réchauffement aide une grande coopération pour
trouver du pétrole en
Antarctique oh ouais et bien ça va
rendre les choses plus faciles ça va faciliter l'
exploitation du pétrole dans l'Arctique ça va aussi
ouvrir les pêcheries ça va
ouvrir ils voient tous les avantages c'est ce qu'ils
en fait  dites bien, vous savez, vous
les écologistes, vous voyez que le verre
est à moitié vide, nous le voyons à moitié plein, nous
voyons, nous voyons le réchauffement climatique comme quelque chose
qui va nous aider économiquement
et cela pourrait être le cas pendant une brève période
de temps, mais cela va  détruisez-nous
écologiquement, je veux dire hier, euh, la
température à Téhéran était de 165 degrés
Fahrenheit, c'est là que 72 degrés
Celsius, je veux dire, qui peut vivre
dans ce genre de situation, vous savez,
et euh, nous voyons des preuves du
réchauffement climatique autour de nous tout le temps.  le
changement climatique et pourtant,
les grands médias grand public nient toujours
qu'il s'agit d'un problème réel, c'est un
problème réel, cela va devenir de plus en
plus problématique,
pensez-vous que l'opinion publique
changerait d'avis sur les questions vertes si nous
étions capables de présenter un  un plan écologique
qui serait économiquement viable
et qui rapporterait de l'argent et
pensez-vous que les médias aideraient à promouvoir
ce plan,
certainement que les gens adopteraient
des idées qui présentent des alternatives
qui vont rapporter de l'argent aux gens,
mais il y a aussi la suppression de
ces idées  par les
compagnies pétrolières et d'autres sociétés qui
voient cela comme des obstacles à leurs
propres profits,
donc ce n'est pas si facile de trouver ces
alternatives et de les promouvoir.
Je veux dire, il y a eu beaucoup de choses qui
ont été avancées comme
des énergies alternatives et des
idées moins nocives pour l'environnement, mais
ils ont été réprimés par les entreprises
qui font réellement des bénéfices et
ils estiment que cela constitue une menace pour
leurs profits. Non, ils ne sont pas juteux,
ils sont juste bloqués par le lobby pétrolier,
beaucoup d'entre eux le sont, oui,
je sais que c'est  loin de ton sujet
mais j'aimerais avoir ton point
de vue sur euh les saoudiens arabes comme on l'
appelle en euh en français tu connais l'arabie saoudite
désolé et dis-moi, dis-moi
quel est ton point de vue sur ce
pays eh
bien, je je  il me semble qu'il y a une
hypocrisie incroyable dans le fait que, par
exemple, les États-Unis
condamnent les
pratiques islamiques en
Syrie, en Iran
et en Afghanistan, mais embrassent l'
Arabie saoudite et la seule raison pour laquelle ils le font, bien
sûr, c'est pour l'argent,
parce que l'Arabie saoudite est un
partenaire économique, donc  parce qu'ils partagent les
mêmes vues économiques, tout
est justifié,
mais je
crois personnellement que l'un
des problèmes de notre monde aujourd'hui,
ce sont les religions anthropocentriques
et toutes,
et donc je pense que le monde serait bien
meilleur si  nous avons aboli l'islam le
christianisme le judaïsme et toutes ces autres
religions qui disent que les êtres humains sont
le centre de la création le centre de l'
univers et les légendes divines toutes-puissantes
que nous pensons être, nous
devons y mettre un terme et est-ce
possible, je ne le fais pas  Je ne sais pas mais je sais
que c'est la racine de beaucoup de
violence et de destruction sur cette
planète, quel est votre point de vue sur
Krishnamurti
Krishnamurti. En fait, j'ai lu euh l'
histoire de la vie de Christian Murthy et je me souviens d'
une fois où  Christian Murty dans les
années 1920 a en fait tenu une conférence de presse
au cours de laquelle il a dit, écoutez, il
n'y a rien de spécial chez moi,
je n'ai pas les réponses,
c'est fondamentalement un canular
et vous savez ce qui s'est passé, il a eu plus de
followers que jamais et c'est à ce moment-là qu'il a
dit d'accord, quoi qu'il en soit.  sera ce que tu
veux que je sois mais il a réalisé que
tout cela n'avait aucun sens il n'y a pas de
gourous il n'y a pas de prêtres il n'y a personne il
n'y a personne qui
a des réponses spéciales oh ouais j'ai une
question sur le boycott parce que depuis que tu as
dit  que tout est une question d'
économie et que le boycott est une
arme économique parce que les gens peuvent avoir
un impact sur l'économie,
préconisez-vous le
boycott, eh bien,
oui et non, je veux dire, le problème avec les
boycotts, c'est qu'ils sont très
difficiles à organiser.  cher à
organiser
et
aussi c'est difficile de les arrêter une fois qu'ils ont
commencé euh mais euh c'est une arme économique valable
ouais il n'y a aucun doute là-dessus,
je veux dire que le premier boycott auquel j'ai jamais
participé était avec le
boycott des raisins de Californie par Cesar Chavez à l'époque
dans les années 1960, ce que j'ai trouvé était
assez efficace, vous savez, pour obtenir
des droits pour les travailleurs agricoles, euh en
Californie et, euh, donc Cesar Chavez a
réalisé pas mal de choses grâce au
boycott du raisin et c'était donc
ma première expérience avec  l'
efficacité des boycotts
il y a un nombre croissant de personnes
qui ont choisi d'être végétarien flexi végétarien ou
végétalien beaucoup d'entre eux ont changé
leur façon de manger et de vivre à cause
de scandales sanitaires et éthiques
pensez-vous que changer nos
habitudes alimentaires aide à lutter pour l'économie  la
planète et sa biodiversité,
je crois absolument que mes navires
sont des navires végétaliens depuis 2000 et des
navires végétariens depuis 1980
et
parce que je crois que nous devons montrer l'
exemple et
que
nous ne pouvons pas sauver le monde en faisant partie
du problème
40 pour cent  de tous les poissons retirés
de l'océan sont donnés en nourriture aux porcs, aux poulets
et au
saumon d'élevage. Lorsque vous mangez un
hamburger, vous mangez en réalité un poisson,
nous mangeons donc littéralement les océans
vivants, nous tuons 65 milliards d'animaux
chaque  Chaque année, dans les fermes industrielles du
monde entier,
nous nourrissons plus de
poisson, par exemple nos
poulets, et nous sommes mangés par les
albatros et les macareux. Les cochons
mangent plus de poisson que tous les phoques de
l'Atlantique Nord. Je veux dire, c'est tout simplement
complètement contre nature.  comportement et je
crois que l'humanité peut
se maintenir en bonne santé grâce à des régimes à base de plantes
qu'ils produisent
utilisent moins d'eau produisent moins de gaz à effet de serre
sont euh
moins une source de pollution
que les produits d'origine animale, alors oui, nous avons
très  euh, nous le promouvons beaucoup, mais nous
le faisons pour des raisons environnementales, euh, nous
ne le sommes pas, vous savez, il existe de nombreuses façons
pour les gens
de promouvoir le véganisme, c'est éthique ou pour leur
santé, mais nous le faisons pour des
raisons environnementales, pensez-vous que les insectes feraient
bien partie de la solution  nous, tu sais, je
sais, je suis allé en Afrique et j'ai vu que
ça fait longtemps, je veux dire, il vole sur le
lac Victoria, je veux dire, il grignote, je veux dire,
mais je pense que nous devons comprendre que les
insectes jouent un rôle incroyable, euh,
incroyablement important.  le but
de faire ce qu'ils font,
cette planète est soutenue et maintenue en
bonne santé par les bactéries, le plancton et les insectes
et nous avons besoin qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils
font,
les abeilles s'assurent que les
plantes sont pollinisées par des vers
et des fourmis et qu'en aérant les
eaux, elles sont fondamentalement les  gardiens
de la planète et nous avons besoin qu'ils le fassent.
Je ne dis pas
que tout le monde dans le monde va
devenir végétarien ou végétalien, peu importe, je
dis simplement que c'est certainement une
alternative
et en particulier pour les nations du premier monde
où  il n'est vraiment pas nécessaire de
manger du steak, du poulet et
tout le reste tous les jours,
euh je veux dire,
tu sais, c'est très difficile
d'aller dans n'importe quelle ville pour
trouver un restaurant où l'on peut réellement
prendre un repas décent maintenant, mais
nous  Nous constatons de plus en plus qu'il y a de plus en plus d'
endroits où vous pouvez faire
cela et les
gens découvrent de plus en plus
que vous pouvez vous maintenir en
bonne santé avec un régime à base de plantes.
Pensez-vous que le modèle du delfinarium est
le lieu marin où se trouvent les mammifères marins ?
gardés en captivité touche à sa fin,
nous travaillons à la fermeture des
delphinariums depuis des décennies et nous
faisons beaucoup de progrès
et nous poursuivons les terres marines maintenant et en
équipe et mais nous
travaillons également à
leur fermeture  dans le monde
en ce moment, il y en a
65 sans excuses
ouais, il y a 65 euh en captivité, euh,
165 d'entre elles sont mortes en captivité et
donc ce que nous travaillons, c'est euh, pour que
ces 65 orques qui sont toujours là soient libres et
préconisons-nous de créer des enclos marins  faites-le,
c'est vraiment une forme d'esclavage et
c'est aussi comme quand vous savez qu'ils ont
attaqué l'Afrique et qu'ils ont tué des gens et
pris les survivants comme esclaves, nous faisons
la même chose au Japon, nous tuons des centaines et des
centaines de dauphins et nous prenons les
les meilleurs et les mettre dans
des delphinariens pour amuser les gens,
ils n'ont pas leur place là-bas, ils sont
extrêmement intelligents, euh, sensibles,
socialement complexes, conscients d'eux-mêmes,
et nous devrions leur donner le respect qu'ils
méritent, ils ne sont pas là pour faire
des bêtises.  astuces pour l'amusement des êtres humains
la dernière question
avez-vous quelques questions à nous poser,
qu'est-ce que vous essayez de faire passer, quel
genre d'informations vous essayez de faire
passer, quel genre de message vous
essayez de faire passer
nous essayons juste de
faire en sorte que les gens se parlent, c'est
tout, vous savez certainement
qu'encourager le dialogue sur toutes ces
questions est important et nous avons besoin
de plus de personnes pour discuter de ces
choses, nous avons également besoin de personnes
pour discuter de ces choses  d'une manière qui
n'est pas si informatique
tout le temps,
les gens sont très polarisés sur
leurs opinions, vous savez, si vous
défendez cette grande opinion, alors vous
n'aimez pas automatiquement les gens qui ont
cette opinion, c'est un autre problème avec
les êtres humains.  que nous avons ce
nationalisme qui naît d'
impulsions tribales probablement primitives, je ne sais pas, je
sais, il y a quelques années, j'ai eu un aperçu
de cela parce qu'il y a
un restaurant aux
États-Unis, il y en a un grand qui s'appelle le
Medieval Times et vous y allez et  vous
prenez un repas médiéval et vous voyez
des chevaliers jouter et des choses comme ça
et
vous êtes assis là, ils vous n'avez pas le
choix où ils vous assoient donc ça se
place dans la section bleue, la
section verte, la section noire peu importe et
ce que j'ai observé là-bas, c'est qu'ils
nous ont fait asseoir dans la section bleue en
20 minutes. Tout le monde dans la section bleue
détestait tout le monde dans la section verte,
tout le monde dans la section verte n'aimait pas que
personne dans la section rouge soit là
pour encourager leur soirée en d'autres termes.
ce que nous avons vu, c'était le nationalisme qui
surgissait sans aucune raison
pourquoi es-tu français tu es né en
France pourquoi es-tu américain tu es né
en Amérique tu sais que c'est la seule
différence entre les gens et alors ils deviennent
fous à cause des morceaux de couleur  des vêtements et des
idéologies différentes qui ne veulent absolument
rien dire, tous les gens sont exactement
les mêmes et
donc je pense que cela va de pair avec
la religion qui, bien sûr, est une autre forme
de division qui
va entraîner la chute de l'
humanité. Toutes ces divisions sont
causées par des raisons artificielles.  des choses comme le
nationalisme et la religion et qu'en
gros, c'est un grand match de football
et tout le monde a une équipe et ils
encouragent les équipes et finalement
ils se battent à ce sujet comme nous le voyons
tout le temps
pour Watson merci merci
[Musique]
toi